what is it about high stakes in a scene
that brings out character secrets
you know high stakes push humans to
react or act in a way
that is more visceral more
uh instinct uh
it's a more instinctual reaction um
than it is a uh
you know then it is something that they
would do like without you know without
those stakes it's that pressure
you know it's that moment that you see a
lot of times where
the plane's about to go down and the guy
somebody confesses everything and then
the plane stops right
uh it's it's the feeling of
terror or this is the end or
i can't take it anymore that pushes
it almost pushes everything it's like
if you can't take any more pressure you
have to relieve
something so sometimes when you add
enough pressure that's when a character
to me kind of goes like okay well
i cheated on you once they're like i did
this you know like
uh you know that that those moments
and i think the real moments i think
there are moments where like
you know human nature where
you you're put in a situation
and you never know if you don't know if
you're going to get out of it but you
want to get something off your chest
or or you want to relieve some other
pressure that's already bubbling up
inside of you
and you just can't take any more of it
um
something's got to give you got to empty
you got to empty the pressure cooker
from somewhere and if even if it's
you know the secret from six years ago
or
the reason why you know you're there in
that situation
or you know whose fault you think it is
or
who you're in love with uh you know
those sometimes help
you know they help they
help kind of keeping that balloon from
popping
or sometimes that balloon pops and
everything comes out
i don't know if that makes complete
sense but yeah it does
that's those are good analogies i like
those okay
you do have a quote from your lookbook
for the film
the most key ingredient to survival is
mental fortitude
refusing to accept that the situation is
hopeless
refusing to accept that there is a
strong possibility that you might die
do you think you also apply this to
filmmaking in a less dramatic way
refusing to think i realize that's a
really strong analogy to use but
when it comes to getting a movie
finished or or a production started
yes uh i yeah
filmmaking is mental fortitude refusing
uh give me the quote one more time i
haven't read it in a while
sure sure um the most key ingredient to
survival is mental fortitude
refusing to accept that the situation is
hopeless refusing to accept that there
is a strong
possibility that you might die yeah i
mean
that quote that quote was written for
our
survival expert um the
yes i would say that filmmaking
um is about mental fortitude as well i
would say that if you
you know you set out to make a project
and you're going to hit
so many walls before you get
you know to any any you know forward
motion
um and sometimes you'll get a you know
a good burst of air and you know you're
like you're
you know there's a there was a great it
wasn't a meme but it was a great like
something that somebody sent me they
were like life of a filmmaker is like
oh my movie's about to get made like oh
it'll never get made oh
uh somebody is interested oh nobody's
interested anymore
like there's an actor that said that
they'll do it like oh we don't have any
money and somebody might give us some
money
you know and you have to go um
you know it's a really it's a really
hard business and it's what i
what i tell a lot of people you don't do
it because
you um you know you really
want to just be if you know be a
filmmaker you almost kind of have to get
some story out there
um i hate to sound cliche when you say
just and say like you don't do it
because you want to you do it because
you have to
um but those people who have gone from
their first film to their second film or
have said like okay i'm gonna go make my
second film
uh
you know that you're going back into a
slog of like really pushing
and really trying to get your movie made
and that there's nothing
really fun about the beginning parts
uh of wrestling with
getting the money getting the right cast
doing the right thing
raising enough money is it enough money
do we need more money
can we you know can you do it for less
money do you really
need this can you you know and making
those right decisions i mean
it's the i know this because i'm doing
it i'm already
doing it right now and uh
you know it's not the fun part of making
your movie
but it's a part that needs to happen so
to go back to that quote like
you have to be mentally strong and
confident in that in this business and
anything
you have to be confident in your product
and what you're and what you're going to
put out into the world um
and you can't you mean
the quote is very dire i mean you know
you may not die but if you give up you
could easily just
fall away in this business and fall or
fall into the background
um and
you know i've
you have to keep keep pushing this pro
your product or keep pushing to get your
stories out there
you